i feel like we're a little subdued i
mean you just won celebrity big brother
congratulations thank you it's been a
lot of processing i don't even know how
to describe what i'm feeling right now
chris kirkpatrick
congratulations misha
you are the winner
of celebrity big brother
it seemed like when they announced it
that you you were there was kind of a
look on your like
is she really i mean huh yes that is
very accurate i was like this is not
real i'm like i'm gonna wake up tomorrow
and i'm still gonna be in this house and
i have yet to win this thing and it was
it's still it's taking me a minute to
process that this is actually done and i
have one celebrity big brother i thought
it was really lovely because in your
speech you were talking about um
how you really did this because you
wanted to be an example for your
daughter i came in here with a goal to
inspire my daughter and my children to
dream big and for my little girl to see
that girls can do it too girls can be
great and amazing and i hope that
um i sent that message to the world do
you think that you've accomplished what
you set out to show your daughter i sure
hope so it makes me emotional just to
think about it and i've been wearing
this obnoxiously fierce blue nail polish
most of all of the challenges for sure i
got it in my first hoh kit and i was
like this is a sign because my
daughter's favorite color is blue and so
whenever i fight i always wear blue or
something blue and i've just brought her
with me and she is my driving force she
is my strength in all of this and i just
wanted her to look at mommy and be like
mommy can do it i can do it and you know
just to know that this world is her
oyster and she can do whatever she wants
so i hope that i did that so i want to
talk about you and todrick because you
all were the dynamic duo since day
number one yeah i know it's early in
this game to make like promises but my
heart feels like we would make a great
final two like you know what i mean like
i love i feel like i just got asked on
the date everybody feared the two of you
i still don't understand as much as i
love big brother i still don't
understand why nobody targeted you all
and got you out yeah i don't get it i
can't believe it i was like there is no
way that we are keeping our butts off
the hot seat this entire season and i
knew i came in and i was like i don't
really know what my strategy is but i
guess i've just got to play hard and try
to win everything and just stay in
control if i can but after that first
hoh i was like
i definitely have a target on my back
the size of the celebrity big brother
house right now and i don't know how i'm
gonna be this is it i'm gonna be
fighting for the rest of the season but
somehow we only had to swerve once yeah
and i don't know i mean maybe it was the
honesty maybe it was just really i was
very upfront with everybody i was like
if i'm targeting you you're gonna know
it if i'm not you're gonna know it and
that's even more of a reason to try to
get you out of the house
but at least maybe they were like well
we'll trust the devil we know yeah and
maybe that's what it was
how important was it for you to stick
with todrick to the very end i mean i
thought that that was a good strategy
and especially at the end
because there's no way i would have
taken cynthia to me the final two
because i think she would have probably
beaten both of you i agree
cynthia was the most amazing sweet kind
mothering figure in the house and i was
like there's no way i'm sitting next to
her because she will take it all
um
however todrick was just somebody i felt
like i didn't know anything about him
coming into this house and it you know
we walk entirely different walks of life
and i feel like um i just felt connected
to him for whatever reason i was drawn
to him and i feel blessed that we
developed this relationship inside the
house
um
and you know when i make a commitment to
someone i'm a very loyal person and i i
like to pride myself that i'm a woman of
my word he ended up in the final two and
you won with a seven to one vote um how
surprised are you that you won by such a
landslide i was very surprised i thought
it was gonna be four and four i was just
trying to predict how i thought
everybody was going to vote and i was
like this comes down to maybe teddy i
was like maybe even mirai because i know
at one point mariah was close to todrick
in the house and had a relationship but
the thing about being stuck in that
bubble for the entire 28 days is we have
no clue what the rest of the world is
seeing what their perception is
we don't know anything and i was like i
don't know what they're gonna think when
they go what's gonna be highlighted and
how it's gonna look and i i had no idea
so that was very surprising to me but i
know you had to hear at the end when
people were voting and casting their
votes that there were a lot of jabs that
were being thrown towards todrick um
which one of those surprised you the
most
um i felt like uh carson um he wasn't
jabbing but i still thought in that
moment that he had voted for todrick and
so i was very surprised to find out that
he hadn't and then todd's reaction i
thought was very uh he seemed very um
rolling his eyes he was doing a lot and
i was like
i mean again we don't really know
um what people are thinking and um you
know i know that i wasn't perfect in the
house i never claimed to be perfect you
know i've probably said some things
that's like you know maybe someone
wouldn't have liked me to say that about
them but it's like i've just tried to be
true to myself and i did the best i
could there were a lot of house guests
you know on the outside now they weren't
too happy with his game and and some of
his words some of his actions in the big
brother house i kind of look at it a lot
as game play and reactions the words you
know whatever but um as somebody who was
very close to him what do you think
about that because i know you're
probably starting to just hear all of
this stuff now
i mean as i mentioned i didn't know
anything about todrick coming into the
house so this is all based on everything
that was in the house and um from what i
understood it when i started to
understand is that this is a
version of us but not not necessarily
you know how we would play it in in the
real world but it is a game and there is
an objective and sometimes lying or
being deceiving or whatever is a part of
that game it's a social experiment and i
thought that him you know finally late
in the game he admitted to me that he
was a super fan and he's watched all 23
seasons and episodes so i think he felt
very comfortable with how the game could
be played which means that it could be
played socially many different ways and
i was kind of like whoa i just had no
idea
um and i think he played the social game
really hard and i thought
like i was like i love todrick i think
he's very genuine he's a great person
and
um you know i hope that people aren't
being too harsh on him but i have again
i have no idea like what is
has been like i don't know when you get
your phone back honey it's going to be a
lot no
my gosh
so what does the 250 000 go to what are
you going to spend it on oh my gosh the
first thing i want to do is just treat
my kids to something i want to i do i
just want to take them i want to buy
them some toys i want to let them know
that
i love them and i didn't just disappear
for no reason you know this is all about
them because they really are my driving
force
[Music]